Rachel Lapierre a fondé le bouc
humanitaire pour les sans-abris dans
l'urgence elle consacre ses journées aux
âmes intoxiquées et esseulés
[Musique]
durant la pandémie elle ajoute une halte
à sa ressource dans cet immeuble suggéré
par la ville les gens arrivent prennent
un repas peuvent utiliser la toilette se
déposent ils vont enlever leur bottes
mouillée leur baume mouillée si on des
problèmes de santé il y a un téléphone
qui va se faire vers moi si au départ
une quinzaine de personnes viennent ici
ils sont maintenant 80 sans abris à
fréquenter l'endroit car peu
d'organismes dans les Laurentides
s'adresse à cette clientèle le soir il y
a pas de salle de bain dans la ville
d'ouverte il y a pas de toilette donc
les gens allaient dans les cours des
voisins pour faire leurs besoins les
policiers et la ville ont reçu de
nombreuses plaintes du voisinage
tiraillés entre un sentiment de
compassion et un désir de quiétude on
pas trop de brasser les choses mais en
même temps mais on est frustré parce que
ça fait du bruit on a passé un été à
entendre crier tout l'été donc tout ce
qu'on espère c'est qu'ils vont sauver un
coin on veut pas les laisser dehors je
pense que ça dépasse ce qui peut offrir
en tant que servir le bouc humanitaire a
été expulsé par la ville il doit quitter
les lieux d'ici samedi si j'avais pas
été du Pokémon
je sais pas où je serai
je peux pas recevoir mes enfants
je peux pas y voir chez nous
certains ont reçu des tentes et se sont
installés dans les boisés pour les
autres on va y aller comme par co on va
voir on va tout mettre en place en tout
cas pour
s'assurer au moins de leur sécurité la
Ville de Saint-Jérôme ne pas réagi c'est
le 6 de Laurentides nous explique que
plusieurs organismes a juste le rêve de
service pour répondre aux besoins dans
la région ici Mélissa François
Radio-Canada Montréal